I'm listening to this podcast about the
Kennedy family and just like about the
children the race whatever and they had
one daughter who was like severely
mentally handicapped the bottom is her
and the podcasters were Rosemary a
rosemary Eunice was her sisters super
into this right now she's the one who
like cared for her and eventually
started the Special Olympics but the
podcast hosts these two girls who are
doing it were saying like
it seems obvious to us that we're like
don't let her get the lobotomy but at
the time fewer than 100 people had gone
through the surgery there was a chance
it was cutting edge they said it worked
so well and it's this crazy gamble which
did not work made her much worse was was
terrible in the end but like
this is this whole it's easier for us to
look back on 1883 or or these time
periods where it was all experimental
they didn't know how they're going to
decide they just needed to